hi I'm William Ross I'm the music
director of the Oscars this year and
this is an Oscar sneak peek we're here
today at Capitol Records we're
rehearsing all the music which we have
quite a bit of we're going over the
songs the production numbers all of that
we've got a a big schedule in front of
us this year we're trying something a
little different the orchestra is gonna
be a Capital Records for the entire show
at the Dolby there's gonna be the show
but we're gonna be fed in it's actually
not that much different from when I'm in
the pit because in the pit very often
they're it's so covered that a lot of
times I have two monitors in front of me
and I'm watching that so instead of
being in the pit I'll be over here we
have a monitor
I hear Don Mischer calling the show and
my headphones everything's happening
just as though we were there this year
the stage design has kind of taken over
a lot of the what would have been the
pit area so we thought that this would
be a good compromise for us to be here
this is one of the largest orchestras I
think ever for the Oscars it's I think
it's 65 people that goes back to Craig
and their commitment to the music they
really are going after this year I know
they have some plans to on some of the
production numbers to shoot the
orchestra because it's much easier to
film here they can set it up it was
always difficult in the pit the pit
there's absolutely no room so I think
you'll see the orchestra more this year
and the past is wonderful as all the
Oscar music has been and I've
contributed that and enjoyed it I think
that it's very interesting that this
year they wanted everything all the
presenter play ons the bumpers all of
those things are going to be music from
classic film scores so it's it's taken
quite a commitment in time and effort to
make that a reality
I get asked about playing people off so
often from people and they turn to me
why do you do that lady it's really not
my call but this year we're doing a
little differently to even that because
remember what I said every piece of
music is from a well-known film I'm not
going to tell you any more than that
okay and folks when we get soft it's not
as for rhythm section it's not a soft it
just stays mean they've been from really
gone after you know just some amazing
artists I mean you know the Mount
Everest of artists you've got Barbra
Streisand coming the same
when was the last time she did that
adele is gonna be here Norah Jones is
gonna be here you know the entertainment
is it's crazy
oh and and they're gonna pass out some
awards know so for music it's a
spectacular